you said that insulin is something that
you didn't want to ever know Trend would
be something else was there anything
else that was completely off the table
for you well I felt like Trend usage
first of all we're not in the old school
era where you're getting like real
Parable in and stuff so you don't really
know and then look at the color of it it
looks like orange you really want to put
something that toxic in your body like
people talk about like okay well it has
to have a filtration rate of such and
such with benzoyl alcohol and therefore
you're going to have the trend coughing
blah blah blah man why am I even wanting
to go through this how many times did I
sit there coughing my lungs out and why
not insulin why do I need it I'm already
winning why do people do it I think they
suffer from the fact that they want
roundness they want fullness in the
muscles because it's the most anabolic
property in the body right I think I
have some of the most well-rounded
muscle we've ever seen why do I need
more I just need more separation I need
more strange that's what I need